[Music]
foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
on Facebook and I'm sister tonight King
Charles prepared to take his place in
history after Doom Laden poles petrol
and protests and frenzy coverage of the
Rogue Royals in California is it now
time to get behind the new king or
debate
and from mistress to Majesty after
decades as the Royal Outsider is Britain
now ready to hail the new Queen Camilla
plus he was a 23 year old flying officer
in the RAF but he took part in Queen
Elizabeth's coronation all the way back
in 1953 the remarkable Terence Debbie
Smith is a part of Royal history and
tonight he joins me and my student
[Music]
from the news building in London this is
Piers Morgan uncensored good evening
from London and welcome to Piers Morgan
on Center the coronation of King Charles
is a global spectacle the eyes of the
world will fall on Britain tomorrow in
our royal family for all the right
reasons Charles will be the 40th Monarch
crowned at the mighty Westminster Abbey
which has hosted every coronation since
William the Conqueror in 1066. just
think about that for a moment that's the
history of this great country well
almost 1 000 years of that history will
echo through that Great Hall as world
leaders have gone and millions are glued
to screens across the world the ceremony
will feature Rings swords and scepters
dating centuries Charles III will be
Anointed with holy oil poured from an
800 year old spoon he'll ride back to
Bucky in Palace in a 260 year old crown
on Wheels the gold State coach which is
dazzled crowds and rattled the teeth of
Royals since the days of William IV
frankly it is what it should be the
stuff of fairy tales and there can't be
a nation anywhere on Earth that can
rival Britain for this kind of tradition
history of the celebrating State
occasions with Pomp pageantry and style
that Journey from Miami to the Palace is
just 1.3 miles but this coronation is in
many ways the Journey of a lifetime the
world has watched Childs as he grew from
a grinning child into a loving father
and a sometimes cantankerous Prince we
speculated for decades about whether the
public would Embrace his elevation to
the crown about whether he could rise
from a shadow of a mother and queen who
seemed infallible at times but now that
moment has arrived and for many people
Charles is not only accepted but
celebrated the Camilla the queen and the
love of his life this has been a journey
like no other two she was The Outsider
shrouded by the memory of Diana so often
Savage by the media reviled by many of
the public but tomorrow she becomes
Queen Camilla and much of a nation has
embraced her strength her wisdom her
empathy and her just get on with its
sense of Duty these are tumultuous times
for the monarchy though there's no
denying that the end of the Elizabethan
age which span changes unprecedented in
history is a major test not just for
King Charles but for the country
Britain's monarchy has faced a scandal
of an errand prince Andrew an
unparalleled Hale of poisoned darts from
the Rogue Royals in Montecito but it's
still here it's still strong and
tomorrow we'll see again but it's still
bringing us all closer together in my
opinion the monarchy keeps our sense of
nation and patriotism separate from
politics it gives us all a reason to
love our country it's traditions and its
identity that rises above The Fray of
the bitterness of everyday debate there
are massive challenges for King Charles
make no mistake about that will today's
young people embrace the Royals well the
Commonwealth survive can an institution
build on stoic silence and illogical
birthrights survive and thrive in the
age of identity politics populism and a
rage against the elites so yes there are
questions about the very future of the
monarchy and there are questions too
about Britain's role in the world at
this turning point of the eras but not
today
this is King Charles's day tomorrow and
it's Britain's day there's been a lot of
negativity in the build up to this
momentous moment there always is the
protester polls the tales of an
apathetic public but what it really
comes down to it I think we do love our
country we love our traditions and we
certainly love a good bloody party let's
do what we do best have a cake have a
quiche wave a flag raise a pint and
enjoy it and for everyone else as my own
son observed this week on Twitter you
may not care about the coronation but I
can very much assure you nobody cares
that you don't care
well I'm joined Now by The Royal
biographer Tom Barr journalist limb
Barber and author historian Dr Tessa
Donna well welcome to my panel this is
probably the a the most erudite and
secondly the most opinionated panel I've
probably ever amassed in the history of
this great country which is fitting for
what we're about to debate tomorrow tom
is the only correlation any of us has
seen I was in 1953 I was just good of
teeth
I've seen you both up to see you would
jump in or a youngster of the younger
generation Tom
I know that so do you have any memories
though oh absolutely you do what do you
remember about the first cramped around
the tiny screen 20 people all trying to
appear at a black and white image
because TV had just come on just come on
and we found someone who had a TV and it
was terribly exciting we learned about
it and then you're the same I remember I
most exciting moment was when
um the peers pierces actually put their
crowns on or what whatever they're
called Coronas and you saw this
wonderful flash of white arms from
nowhere it's like the ballet it was a
certain magic I think probably because
television was black and white which I
think makes everything look classier but
obviously because also Tessa because
Queen Elizabeth was 26 years old and
beautiful yeah and it was almost like
this ex you know it's like a Hollywood
event of this beautiful young Starlet
but you know exceeding after the tragedy
of her father dying Charles doesn't have
the benefit of any of that he has
multi-color he has social media he has
aged not on his side it's a it's a tough
challenge for him well it's really
interesting I've spoken with a lot of
veterans who remember that I feel
fatally ridiculous I just wanted to try
I wasn't going to mention what you're
doing well in a tiara and I feel
ridiculous how do they carry it off I
don't know but anyway back to the matter
I had I speak to a lot of veterans and
they remember that day and they recall
feeling compassion towards Elizabeth the
unimpeachable the blemish free young
woman of vulnerability they went home
and prayed for her that night but
bizarrely I actually think tomorrow
because of his age because of his check
had passed because of where we're at as
a nation and our relationship with the
crown I think Charles is a hundred times
the more vulnerable than his mother was
70 years well I think that's right and
Tom you know you've you've monitored the
Royals now very assiduously for quite
some time it does feel like a pivotal
moment in the potential future of this
monarchy well does and the question
really is whether a child can actually
build a rain which is separate obviously
to his mothers but actually improves
impresses the country and the people and
bills uh following for the royal family
and monarchy and that is a huge
challenge for him the poll the polls the
most recent polls show that there's a
lot of support here for Charles not
quite so strong in other parts of the
Commonwealth and I interviewed the Prime
Minister of Australia this week who is a
Republican and made it pretty clear you
know they want the end of a British
royal as the head of state well they've
always said that for years and have
managed to produce an alternative well
Charles actually is not that popular
he's only 54 in the mail poll and
monarchy is about most politicians would
take that well yes I know but I mean the
queen had over 70 yeah but she was look
let's be honest the queen Lynn was a
unique public figure I think in modern
history it's hard to think of anyone
with her I think profound Global respect
yeah really and a sort of untarnished
rain in many ways I mean to follow that
is almost impossible
but I mean in theory I want us to be a
republic but it isn't going to happen is
it I mean because how would it happen
why would you want us to be a republic
what I think is bad to be called
subjects I don't want to wear subjects I
don't want to well we've had we've had
to call Boris Johnson the right
honorable gentleman I mean we do use
titles for elected officials which make
my skin crawl okay but yeah just the
sort of bowing and scraping in general
but here's the but I think the reason
for the monarchy the reason I love the
idea of it and the fact that we have
this royal family is it's almost unique
now in the world there are other
monarchies they're not as famous as ours
and nobody does Pomp pageantry and
ceremony like the Brits and I all my
American friends they'll all be tuning
in tomorrow because they love Tessa they
love the carriages the coaches they love
the military possession and this one by
the way this is staggery statistic so
the procession tomorrow is going to be
twice as big as the procession for the
Queen's funeral and three times the size
of the procession for the Platinum
Jubilee both of which felt enormous the
truth is where paper and over our
insecurities I'm sorry I have a problem
FaceTime this man I don't always agree
with that we'll end up having a book
with this on your head
um the truth is historically we didn't
do Pomp and pageantry we didn't bother
with it for victorious coronation for
William the force coronation when
Britannia did controversially an
unchallenged ruler waves when we start
getting insecure in the late 19th
century the early 20th century that's
when we muscle up we re-front Buck pal
we make the mile wider we get all the
music Elder tralala and then we go for
Paris
absolutely actually no because actually
the last coronation came just a few
years after Little Britain stood up to
Nazi Germany and saved this country and
its freedoms and I think the Pomp
pageantry and ceremony of our great
military processions actually emanated
from the fact that yes when it actually
came to it Little Britain stood up and
punched okay big bad Hitler in the face
and save this country I don't agree with
you you can both have 70 years ago I'll
give you that as a buy but I would argue
that today we don't need I'm going to go
with it because it'll look tragic if we
always went droop tomorrow we'd got
everyone out in the horses and
characters and there was no one there
but I actually think it's unnecessary
we've had this glut of Royal events
we've all done very well fed off the
carcass of Pomp and ceremony but I
actually wonder how will this be viewed
by history do you think this will be our
last coronation Tom no I don't at all I
think that might be desperately is the
monarchy and I think the monarchy is
very important for the country yeah but
the question really is today
when you defend the monarchy what what
what do you give us the best
justification for it the alternative is
far worse right yeah with President
Blair or president or president Boris
Johnson but also you know when uh
Princess Anne or the king or whoever
goes to visit a hospital or hospice or
School Factory the people they're really
welcomed yes as individuals who are
sincerely interested in their work and
their problems and all the
confrontations they have which a
politician will only be interested for
their own vote so I think there's the
whole charitable side is brilliant on
the monarchy I think Charles is a very
flawed character I think he comes to the
throne with enormous amount of baggage
but tomorrow is the day actually having
written a book which is color skating
about him well he's got to put that to a
side well he's got to think he now
represents an institution the fate of
the monarchy and for King William in the
future and also in the animals that is
very important right and then the annals
of King history he's not that bad we've
had some Shockers um let me ask you
the unmentionables the Montecito Rebels
Harry and Megan yes what do you make of
them should we make anything more of
them should we just forget about that I
think we will increasingly forget about
them I mean I think they're they've
peaked as it were and I think the King
was quite right to invite them I mean it
would look really awful living do we
believe that Meghan Markle isn't coming
because her son's four that day well
I mean I've heard some Whoppers in my
time from her but nothing quite as
ridiculous as that the idea she would
give up being at Center Stage to
coronation for that is laughing it
doesn't it actually was if it wasn't
going to be sent to Stage that's why I
think that may be why she isn't coming
yeah why do you think she's not examine
I think because she knows the latest
polls show that their popularity is yeah
an all-time low yeah the write down with
prince Andrew and there's a very good
likelihood that the British public will
boo her pretty loudly but the truth is
whether she should be there or shouldn't
be there or whatever's kept her away the
Optics
with her
platform for the world tomorrow the eyes
are honest I don't understand given the
soft power that Charles has as king head
of 14 other Arms Why are all the
composers of the new music British why
are all the page boys white in English
why haven't we lent into these
relationships sitting on a plate for us
still we just take them for granted no
wonder half of them are pulling away I
think we've dropped the ball though what
do you reckon Lynn well I didn't know
that they were all white and they aren't
surprised
um I'm sorry all the page boys
because we thought we're talking about
now for God's sakes stop the diversity
argument today of all days it's the day
before the coronation is not going to be
an extraordinary event celebrating
British greatness and history in a
thousand years the diversity argument
surely can be silenced just today
absolutely
I look I I think actually it's an
interesting point I wasn't aware it was
going to be quite as you've depicted
let's wait and see tomorrow actually
what we end up seeing I don't think you
can ignore race simply because Megan and
Harry have put race center stage of
their critique about the royal family
and that's made actually I think a lot
of countries in the Commonwealth that's
right particularly in the Caribbean you
see really agitated about this notion
that the royal family are a bunch of
racism well that's absolutely right and
that's exactly why I think we should
stop today discussing it because it was
Megan's agenda and she created it and I
think that is untrue because anyone has
really hard worked hard to embrace the
all the different faiths and communities
in Britain it's child I totally agree it
has continuously gone to visit all sorts
of places and the princess trust has
helped so many uh minorities get on
there get on their careers all the rest
of it so it's just totally unfair untrue
will you be watching absolutely will you
be watching yes I will and even as a
Republican
any of you'd be saying the oath
Tom doesn't like damn well well he never
looked at me when we're discussing don't
only look at peers I'm here too actually
he's looking at the person who show it
is
sometimes you're a little confused
tester you think it's your show and you
ask the questions
um great to see you all it's going to be
an amazing day I just think we do with
stuff better than anybody else and well
I'm sure rake over the coals of it next
week but for tomorrow let's just come
together and let's celebrate being
British at our very best so thank you to
my panel well on sense of next I'll be
joined in the studio this is
extraordinary a veteran of a 1953
coronation fly pass retired Squadron
leader Terence Devi Smith a living
legend he was part of that flyby for the
queen in 1953 and he'll be flying by
into the studio after the break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
experience tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mug we've
got the fun thing and Paul what is good
about Britain our King if you want the
real ground then tune in to talk TV for
a rights Royal point of view God Save
the King
[Music]
thank you
Disney
I've been photographing the same family
for 45 years
I followed their lives across four
generations
[Music]
I think about what I've done and who
I've met and what I've seen I can't
believe it
[Music]
thank you
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV for a right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mud we've
got the fun team and Paul what is good
about Britain our King if you want the
real crown then tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view God Save the
King
thank you
[Music]
well welcome back to PS4 consensus on
the eve of this historic coronation of
King Charles III 70 years ago retired
Squadron leader Terence Debbie Smith and
his team were chosen to perform the RAF
fly past for the Queen's coronation
Terence the Judith flyer meteor aircraft
over the palace to Mark Britain's
transition to a queen as Monarch and bad
weather put the fly past in Jeopardy but
a last minute call to send them up was
made after conditions improved it needed
to say the Squadron leaders contribution
to the 1953 flight pass has not been
forgotten in preparation for King
Charles's coronation he was invited to
be the guest at honor at Raf cramwell in
Lincolnshire during April's fly past
rehearsals and I'm genuinely honored to
say that Terence joins me now well great
to see you Terence thank you very much
indeed for coming here I was reading
about your story and I thought I've got
to get this guy in because the idea that
you were there flying over the skies for
Queen Elizabeth when she became Queen
and here you are today and we're on the
eve of another great coronation it makes
you part of British history
is is it that uh I I would love to fly
tomorrow but uh you won't be going up
tomorrow I I I won't be flying tomorrow
do you do you remember well that day
back in 1953 when you flew over very
difficult to forget yeah
um the I suppose the most memorable
thing was that the weather with Paul
weather and we were
just
drank about six gallons of of coffee
we're waiting to for the to say go
eventually they said go
round about I can't remember now four or
five o'clock in the afternoon and off we
went what was the feeling like for you
obviously you were a very accomplished
pilot but what was the feeling like to
be taking part in this moment of History
well great great great honor because it
was to fly in close formation uh it did
demonstrating our skills in front of her
majesty and you'd met the queen before
the coronation actually yes she she'd
come down to visit your squadron and you
actually lent her your pen
you gave her your pen to use I think too
uh yep I was fortunate when I was in ADC
at the time yeah
um to uh the uh see his
commander-in-chief a home command
um yeah it's um she was about to
well if she was offered the the things
on people just saying
because the pen should have been there
on on the table
but he wasn't but you came to the rescue
yeah
what was she like the young Queen then
to me oh super super well they all are
all the royal family are and I'm I'm a
great royalist and
well I'm a royalist
um when people say as some people do
what's the point of the royal family and
the monarchy it's anachronistic we
should get rid of it what do you say to
them
I'd say a rude word which I can't repeat
what do they mean to you why is it
important that we have this this royal
family they're the symbol of everything
which was which is which is great about
England but about British Isles rather
great great with Great Britain because
we have the Royal Family
I feel there are murmurings that Charles
can't be as popular as his mother and
this will hasten the end of the monarchy
do you do you think not a Christian
popularity is he's going to be a very
good King in my opinion why do you think
that
because he listens
I think that's one of the things
um he listens and uh he's he's got the
right ideas and uh he wants to do
he wants to want to achieve something
there's no country in the world that
does Pomp and pageantry and Military
processions like Britain I think what
was it like to actually take part in one
I mean how did you did you celebrate
afterwards with your colleagues too true
we did yeah
oh yes it's uh we've been on tender
hooks for about six seven hours and
eventually as I said the uh the air
marshal sitting on or standing on pacing
up and down the top of the roof of the
Balkan Palace and finally said if he
sends the weather was improving so he
said just go
and there were huge crowds of course of
people no no I guess I imagine that was
that the highlight of your career
up to then it was yes yeah did you have
something later that uh well not not to
that extent no no
when you look back you have your log
book here from the day and you have some
pictures of you from that day does it
bring back great memories for you
wonderful memories are any of your
colleagues from that day are they still
alive no I do I don't know you never see
them I I don't see them no no it's um
you leave the Air Force and you you go
and develop civil civilian life and uh
um
no I'd like to see them but what did you
go on to do when you when you left the
RAF
when I left the Air Force um went into
um Commerce
uh
I was
a company secretary what does it mean to
you Terence to be to be British
tomorrow the eyes of the world will be
on this country what does it mean to you
to be British oh absolutely
um
it's wonderful it's it's we are number
one
um the best country in the world
well I think so uh what what makes this
such a great country do you think
um
because we've
tried to develop help other countries to
develop without trying to dominate them
you've had an amazing life yes and and
you've reached a wonderful age where
will you be watching the coronation
tomorrow
oh in uh at home on television
in full color which it wasn't back in
1954.
normally I've had a screen about that's
that why now I've got one that one
did you feel tremendous pressure when
you were on that flyby that day no no
because we we've rehearsed time and time
and time again
um uh fire flying in close formation so
and you trusted everyone else around you
that they weren't going to do anything
bloody stupid
so and when you finished Terence when
you were done and you all landed and you
realized it had been a huge success was
that a huge relief to everybody oh yeah
yeah we're a buoyant yeah
apart from being full of wines and beer
as well
the queen very sadly died last year yeah
what impact did that have on you when
when you heard that news I I was very
very very sad very very suddenly but she
really was a great Queen
but I think any member of the royal
family is going to to take her place
Charles has gone King Charles from is I
think going to be a very good King I
think I think he will I think he has
very good qualities yes I think I
believe so and I think Queen Camilla as
she will be has turned out to be a great
Rock for him why not yeah he chose her
so he
you've got I'm sure he's got good good
taste yeah Terence it's it's wonderful
to see with all your memories and your
log book when what was the entry for the
log book do you remember
yes just um coronation coronation review
fly past that's it that's it yes very
understated yeah well that's all it is
all everything else is out up there
did you ever work out how many people
around the world would have been
watching you that day
no Millions like hundreds of millions
well I suppose bound to be yeah an
amazing moment in history but a great
honor to have you here Terence no no no
no it's been thank you for inviting me
here and here you've got a beer because
you did a lot of great work you raise
money for the defense medical
Rehabilitation Center in Loughborough
which is your badge there and that's
your coronation medal there which is
fantastic and this is the beer that the
charity does the benevolence beer do you
recommend this Terence I do a nice drop
and I recommend the the the the the
charity the charity it's an excellent
charity it does cracking beer so if you
can raise some money the defense medical
Rehabilitation Center in Loughborough
Terrence great to meet you and great to
interview thank you very much indeed
thank you very much and uh what an
amazing thing to have done in your life
incredible
obviously thank you very much yeah
bye-bye well on Thursday next she's had
a long and difficult road to public
acceptance but a decades is the Royal
Outsider is the nation ready to hail
Queen Camilla we'll debate that next
foreign
[Music]
experience tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mud we've
got the fun team and Paul what is good
about Britain our King if you want the
real crown then tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view God Save the
King
thank you
[Music]
foreign
family for 45 years
I followed their lives across four
generations
[Music]
I think about what I've done and who
I've met and what I've seen I can't
believe it
[Music]
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV for a right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mud we've
got the fun thing and Paul what is good
about Britain our King if you want the
real crown then tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view God Save the
King
[Music]
thank you this is talk TV
welcome back to Facebook and uncensored
from Queen consort to Simply Queen
kimono will go buy a new title following
the coronation tomorrow represents a
long journey in the Public's eye from
the Royal Outsider often Savaged by the
media and the public to woman prays for
her wisdom and get on with its Spirit
she also of course won over the lake
Queen Elizabeth who backed her to be
Queen consort at the start of her
Jubilee year Her Majesty wrote a public
letter which she said in the fullness of
time my son Charles becomes king I know
we'll give him and his wife Camilla the
same support you've given me and it's my
sincere wish that when that time comes
Camilla will be known as Queen consort
if she continues her own loyal service
so after a pretty Rocky history with the
public is the nation ready to hail Queen
Camilla well joining me now is the
former private secretary to Princess
Diana Patrick Jefferson the talkative
contributors Esther cracker and Ava
Santina welcome to all of you Patrick
could you have ever imagined when we
used to occasionally chat in the Diana
days
particularly actually after the tragedy
of Diana's death in 1997 that here we
would be
20 odd years later
about to have Camilla crowned queen of
this country
in the immortal words of Meghan Markle
love wins right
no I mean it is it is an extraordinary
Journey as you've described it yes I
mean the
the opportunity to even imagine
something like that just didn't come my
way it isn't it is I think for Palace
strategist the job isn't done depending
which pole you look at either 86 or even
90 of people don't approve of the
terminology the term Queen right now
they'll give her a lot of ground I've
actually had people say to me I thought
the Queen Elizabeth said she was going
to be Queen consort what happened to
that and when did when did it become
Queen and they do have a bit of a
problem with that I don't but they do
well because they remember the queen and
you know people talk about the queen and
people remember the queen trying to
readjust recalibrate to Queen Camilla it
does seem strange and you can ask did
the late Queen have an idea in her mind
when she said Queen consort she meant
what she said yeah she did it was in
writing Esther it is a bit of a hot
potato they've had a few this week the
oath of Allegiance went down like a lead
balloon most people just want nothing to
do with that but this issue of whether
she should be Queen the queen or
Charles's Queen console it's a big
difference actually I think because the
queen was so highly respected I think
they should have stuck exactly what she
said and just made her Queen concert I
think you are pushing it we're just
saying Camilla is the queen especially
because there's a generation of people
that really remember the whole Camilla
Diana Charles Saga that are not over it
there's always going to be that wound
there as Camilla was The Other Woman and
as much as she's a toned and people
understand that people grow and change I
think you're pushing it with Queen
Camilla Ava do you care do you know this
is the one part of that I do care about
because I mean it's going to shock you
I'm not a monarchist but the one thing I
like is the pom and the ceremony and the
ritual and so for me Camilla can't be
Queen Diana is Queen she will be and
she's she won't be queen and the queen
size either
but you know what I would have loved
more I would have loved to have seen
what Diana would have worn I would have
loved it oh yeah well actually I would
read at all I would have loved I knew
Donna quite well I would love to have
seen Donna's face at the moment that
Crown goes on Camilla's head I mean
Patrick I don't think it's probably
breaking any discreet secrets to say she
wouldn't have been happy well well you
know Pierce Diana always surprised you
um that is true and you know Andrew
Parker Bowles is going to be in the
congregation I know
um
and Diana
she was she was an extraordinarily
mature and wise woman in many ways and
she recognized that her husband needed
this person for whatever reason she
couldn't fathom it necessarily but she
said you know he needs this woman and
Diana was reconciled to that largely and
I think that for her uppermost she had a
great love for her husband and the
thought that if if this other woman
could make him happy I think she would
have made her peace with that she would
have had her own life to get on with and
it would have been fantastic that's true
and I think um I mean I I've got to
learn Camilla quite well over the years
we've actually come from neighboring
villages in East Sussex literally a mile
apart so we always had that little
connection and uh I really like her
she's a very down-to-earth warm
no-nonsense kind of person all her
family are sisters the same
um and she's been indisputably as to
whatever we think of the the love issues
there the triangle and so on the three
of us are Miss marriage she has been a
constant Rock for Charles and I think if
it hadn't been for her I would have
really really concerned about him oh
absolutely I think she's really sort of
centered him in many ways but also she's
also a very strong woman I've often made
the point that I couldn't have gone
through what she went through and still
had chosen to I mean when Meghan Markle
bleeds about media exactly I mean she's
not even a first base Camilla had 30
years of this and it was vicious I mean
far worse
no you've got no idea this is the
trouble you youngsters you have no idea
I still get messages from my mother
saying how can Camilla and I'm like you
know I don't think the internet will
ever recover from Diana what could have
been what what could it be I do forget
people often forget Diana had her own
life and she also had her own up there
you know what here's the truth about
everyone involved in this Andrew Parker
Bowles Camilla Charles Diana let me tell
you the common denominator they all had
a fortnight yeah they all had affairs
all of them yeah right so the idea
there's some angel in the middle of this
or some you you know guy who's been
badly treated it doesn't stack up to the
actual facts they all had affairs and it
was messy but out of it all Camilla's
retained a great love and good
relationship with her ex-husband Andrew
he'll be there at the coronation and I
think Dinah would have come to terms
with this actually I think she knew she
knew that Charles is great love probably
in the end was Camilla but Pierce don't
you think that the issue here is not
Camilla it's what happened because of
Camilla it's that total reset of
relations between the palace and the
media and not in a good way it's totally
corroded that relationship because in
order to reinvent Camilla Charles's
office had to import political style
spin to Royal media relations and they
have never recovered that may be true
but there may have been no other way I
want to say a little clip this is Tom
Parker Bowles Camilla's son a great guy
this is what he said
but does it feel weird for you to start
sort of having
as the queen not really because she's
still you know our mother I say ah
speaking not not the Royal East with
sweets my sister and me
um but she is oh yeah she's our mother
and it's I think change happens but I
don't care what anyone says this wasn't
any sort of end game she married the
person she loved and this is what
happened
he's great Tom but I mean I sat next to
Camilla When Donald Trump was in town
and she'd just been with him for the day
with Charles and I sat next to dinner
that night and I won't reveal what she
said about it but she was hilarious
about it and I just felt that she could
do anything Camilla she's she's a
perfect console for one of a better
phrase for Charles she's always there
just gets on cracks on whether it's
Donald Trump with all that chaos coming
into town or whether it's a small
dutiful Act of some small charity that
they're going to she just seems nothing
phases it and that's a powerful tool for
someone in her position no absolutely I
think one of the the things that has
been missing is the word Duty right I
think Camilla is gives gives people that
she the sense that she has a sense of
Duty which some members or former
members of the royal family I can't say
have always had that and I think that's
pretty refreshing and she said to me you
know uh she said there's an easy way to
do this you said you just it's never
complain yeah never explain yeah and
rarely be heard speaking in public I
mean I think that was a it was a queen
mother template actually which the queen
certainly had Camilla has she's never
engaged over in any of the and I promise
you it was 10 times whatever you think
Meghan markle's had Camilla was Savaged
by the media by the public by everybody
everyone like you loved Diana I love
Donna she was a fantastic person had
great lunches with her I would speech on
the phone about stuffing you know all
sorts of stuff used to go on behind the
scenes when Harry wants to know where
most of the best juicy stories came from
trust me often his mother right so she
could manipulate the meter as Patrick
knows better than anybody
um I didn't blame her because she was on
the receiving end of it but I think that
uh with this one I think when you start
getting into the blame game you're
missing the bigger point which is
actually they all had their problems and
in the end the Charles commit a love
story is a big real one yeah possibly
can I introduce to an internet term
that's going around on a tech talk most
under 40s are using it's uh what is it
side chick
green Camilla is the ultimate what does
that mean perseverance it means if you
are the third woman who's hung on long
enough he will change and he will uh
with you yeah
[Laughter]
as millions of Brits prepare to roll out
the bunting for a weekend of Royal
further why did polish show that young
people are the least likely to be among
them we have a couple of youngins in
today and what can the new King Charles
do to win back the youth debating that
next
[Music]
thank you
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV for a right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mud we've
got the Bunting and Paul what is good
about Britain by growing our King if you
want the real crown then tune in to talk
TV for a right Royal point of view God
Save the King
assistant
[Music]
foreign
photographing the same family for 45
years
I followed their lives across four
generations
[Music]
I think about what I've done and who
I've met and what I've seen I can't
believe it
[Music]
thank you
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV for a right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mud we've
got the Bunting and Paul what is good
about Britain our King if you want the
real crown then tune in to talk TV for a
right Royal point of view God Save the
King
[Music]
thank you
the Royals remain a much larger
respected institution in the UK overall
but it's King Charles losing the hearts
and minds of a younger generation of
slur recent polls suggests you might
just one third of young people said
they'd back the monarchy in appalled by
British future earlier this week or my
pack is still with me Patrick I'm much
of a concern is this and obviously
Charles tomorrow when he has the
coronation you know he's what is he 50
odd years older than his mother was when
she became the queen as a young
dazzlingly beautiful princess it's a
very different optic for him much harder
to appeal to the youth yes but I think
it's probably quite a healthy sign I can
remember you remember stuff the Jubilee
yes back in the 70s and 80s the younger
generation it's their job to be
skeptical about this sort of thing I'd
be more worried if they were all for it
well yeah what do you think because
young people like myself we're
counter-cultural we it's cool to not be
with the modern thing or what's
happening now and I also think the
things that concern young people are
completely different to what concerns
older people I don't know a single young
person under 24 that's thinking about
pensions or saving up or passing
anything on to their future Generations
they're thinking of how to get drunk
every weekend and just live life so the
things that concern my generation are
completely different to what concerns
all the generations that are thinking
about leaving things to their children
and but if you were advising Charles
right what advice would you give them
about how to resonate with young people
I don't think there's very much you can
do I think obviously be an example but I
think talk well I just don't think
that's his thing but I think most young
actually younger people want more to um
Kate and William than him which is makes
sense because they're over younger
generation still
um so I think he can just do the best he
can ultimately I think when the crime
passes to William it will change the
dynamic will continue to change over I
think the problem that certainly the
office of the palace however you want to
call it has is well mainly comes with
this oath that they tried to force down
our throats last week young people are
rejecting that we don't want well I
rejected that and thank you for calling
me young
welfare you know we don't want to swear
allegiance to a crown or to people that
basically suck money from the estate
when we're living in a country where
people are actually starving I see I
would assess it if I've been them I'd
have flipped it and had Charles saw an
oath of allegiance to the British people
yeah I think that would have been a neat
way of modernizing the monarchy and one
Fell's work actually you know one thing
I have to praise him for I love his
environmentalism I think that's really
interesting he's been right about that
for decades he has been but I just don't
think we're in this space anymore where
we want Pomp and ceremony we don't I
couldn't disagree more with you you kill
Joy no you see acquiesce tomorrow the
eyes of the world tomorrow will be on
this great country in our capital city
and they're going to see the greatest
procession since the first coronation
this dwarfs anything we've seen since
then Dorset honestly it's going to be
gigantic where am I watching it from my
rented property because I can't buy a
house in this country I'm so sorry
you're not homeless I'm so sorry
it doesn't interest people under 40
anymore when you can't afford a good
lifestyle you don't want to watch
something
honestly you're under 40. well yeah well
yes it does every single person under 40
apart from you disagrees with me I'm
sorry no but it's I think the politics
of Envy is not a way to justify trying
to get rid of such an age-old
institution you may not be particularly
enthusiastic about it which is fine but
I do think that the idea that because
it's old it's lost its values quite
frankly a very childish thing to think
now I completely understand there is a
cost of living crisis but you can't say
we can only have a coronation when there
are no homeless people and everything is
perfect I'm saying no coronation at all
do you know one thing I really don't
like the anti-strike laws which were
given Royal Ascent on Tuesday they're
coming into Choice it means even in this
country where we have free speech you
are not allowed to go and protest the
coronation if you want to actions like
that are not good for the crown well
listen I agree with peaceful protests
but why ruin the party for people yeah
if you don't like it just go away go
into something else I'll be staying go
to the pump strike laws because you're
civilizer some people are less civilized
so quietly protesting where I shan't be
arrested actually where will you be
tomorrow watching this uh I will be
working I'm going to be in Methodist
Central Hall
um and that's a great location from
which to see all the fun just going back
to the point about how Charles wins back
the younger generation
the one thing he should not be tempted
to do is try to get down with the kids
he does this sometimes he is what he is
he needs to be authentic if there's one
thing young people spot it's a fake well
it's interesting the other day in
Liverpool there was a really interesting
moment where a lot of protesters turned
up and we're giving him hell and then
there was a counter reaction from some
young people watch this
he's okay
[Music]
there you go
so cute there are people young people
Ava without your cynicism without your
politics of Envy who've been taught by
their teachers
when they grow up remember my 11 year
old daughter's very into it she loves
she loves the idea of a royal family a
monarchy and all the rest sure but you
believe in choice right and Free Speech
yes we should be allowed to say we don't
believe in the monarchy you are very we
are very welcome to do that but I don't
think that's going to take you very far
because young people don't know very
much generally speaking it's a bit like
to me it's a bit like being a noisy
atheist it's like if you don't believe
in God we'll find a shut up no what's he
got to do with you because I have to why
spend your time so I'm yapping at people
who do it's a bit like Auntie monarchist
it's like What's it gonna do with you it
costs you one p isn't it one piece and I
don't want to pay that one a day I would
rather that accumulated money went
towards something I care about really a
week yes I'd much rather than it well
why don't you make it a subscription
service what do you drink why did you
make it when you go to the pub what do
you drink I'm a I'm a lager girl of
course yeah
how much is the panda logo in a London
pub 580 if you're lucky
five pounds
right that's more
that's the only Bill you would have for
a British royal family which is the
pride of the world okay you pay it for
me and don't make me pay it you know
what I'll put your little skin Flint I
will pay your 7p a week for the monarchy
if that makes you feel better okay okay
so you get them for free you get all the
benefit of them if you had a
subscription model people would opt out
people would no absolutely uh I don't
agree with that that was a poll out just
this afternoon Savannah commissioned
nearly 50 of people want to see an end
of the monarchy if you told people
actually the amount of money you put
into the BBC license fee we're going to
move that to the monarchy would you be
happy with it now why are you there
we'll talk about the BBC I don't want to
act like that that's the fair point I
don't watch it as a fair point you are
when you're making a fair point of
course you should be allowed to not want
a monarchy we live in a free country the
whole point of a democracy like ours is
you're allowed to have that view right I
mean it's fine you just happen to be
wrong
how am I meant to come back to that
pierce You Love free speech you should
advocate for me going down the mall this
weekend and protesting you know I come
from a family so my my mother camped on
the mouth of both Diner and Fergie's
weddings to Charles and Andrew and I and
we had I remember we ran a country Pub a
little village in Sussex 1977 the Silver
Jubilee um of the street parties all
around including our entire Village was
done up like a big bunting lead party it
was fantastic and I loved it I think
maybe that's why I feel so kind of into
all this because I think it gives us
something a little bit magical and yeah
they're flawed yes they've got some
Renegades yes we could do without Andrew
and is Shenanigans we could do without
Harry and Megan and their yapping of
course we could the rules have always
been flawed end of the eighth wasn't a
great guy you know he chopped off his
wives heads right so it's all relative
But ultimately tomorrow we're going to
see this country at its absolute best
right Patrick well yes but I think a bit
of History helps too you've got 20
seconds for this history Charles the
first had his head chopped off because
he lost the people yeah if are you
suggesting this King might get better
Modern monarchs lose the people then
they won't get their head chopped off
but the modern equipment you're right
they
solitary lesson so less of your cynicism
more positivity please Ava thank you
Esther thank you Patrick great to see
you all gonna have an amazing day
tomorrow whatever you're doing get out
there and watch it because it's us and
our best I'm Gonna Leave You with the
Fantastic Catherine Jenkins been with us
all week of course singing what else God
Save the King Keep It Uncensored
foreign
[Music]
Victorious
thy choices
[Music]
beautiful
look at me
[Applause]
[Music]
even
gracious King
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV for a right Royal point of view
watch along with Sharon he is a
humanitarian and he's going to do a
great job Vanessa we can't wait we're
counting down we've got the mud we've
got the Bunting and Paul what is good
about Britain our King if you want the
real crown then tune in to talk TV for a
rights Royal point of view God Save the
King
[Music]
thank you
I've been photographing the same family
for 45 years
I followed their lives across four
generations
[Music]
is